[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment un honneur d'être invité
si ce soit et c'est avec plaisir que je
nord 7 invitait ce sens que je vais
passer côté un peu numérique est ce que
le monde comment il a évolué dans les
dernières années et travers les
inventions et puis le rôle du digital et
l'économie cyclique
alors j'ai préparé quelques informations
on va commencer au début par parler sur
les inventions comment elles ont évolué
à travers les siècles
à cette heure ci voudrait être avoir un
peu faim il existait une société en 1926
qui s'appelait effectivement au
frigidaire et thomas mich a été
l'inventeur de cycle frigorifique où il
a trouvé que le gaz frion pouvaient en
fait faire le cycle frigorifique qui
permet de conserver les aliments et qui
permet en fait après de les réutiliser
après pour nos besoins
alors ce travail qui a permis d'inventer
le frigidaire a évolué après aujourd'hui
ce qu'on retrouve on va trouver des
machines communicantes donc ta partie
qui devenait en fait très important qui
est la partie à nos ventes est devenu
une commodité et aujourd'hui ce qui
donne le plus important c'est le côté
communicants des frigidaires donc on va
trouver plutôt un ordinateur quand vous
le voyez c'est sur l'image qui va vous
dire à quel moment où vous devez vous
approvisionner quels sont les calories
vous avez consommé
et savoir d envoyer des informations qui
vont en fait gérés un peu le cycle
alimentaire et d'approvisionnement chez
nous deuxième exemple c'est l'avancement
de la machine à vapeur en 1769
alors c'était à l'origine de tous les
trains les voitures même le premier
avion volant il était à machine à valeur
s'était à l'époque qu'une révolution est
la plus grande utilisation des machines
à vapeur c'était surtout pour la
révolution industrielle au début du
siècle
alors aujourd'hui on va trouver quelque
chose qui n'a rien à voir à l'époque
avec l'invention
si les trains à suspension magnétique
alors ce train c'est un train qui fait
shanghai et l'aéroport de charjah entre
le centre l'aéroport c'est à peu près 30
km il va jusqu'à 450 km à l'heure il
fait cela en 7 minutes et 20 secondes en
moyenne
il fait à peu près de 150 climatologues
puisque au début il faut pas démarrer
très vite et puis à l'arrivée il faut
pas aussi atterrir très vite c'est pour
ça qu'ils invitaient ce moyen après ce
monsieur c'est c'est pas effectivement
l'inventeur du calculateur
c'est fort neumann il a invité le
premier calculateur architecture qui
s'appelle donc l'ordinateur qui est un
système d'exploitation et c'était en
1946 alors derrière ce monsieur vous
voyez des armoires alors ça ça pesait à
peu près 25 tonnes ça avait une rapidité
qui faisait 5 milliards 5000 instruction
par seconde et ça pouvait remplir
peut-être cet amphithéâtre complètement
donc à partir de là on est passé à
quelque chose qui est des
microprocesseurs qui fait à peu près ils
sont 1 2 g et qui vont faire au fait des
calculs de 25 milliards par seconde et
aujourd'hui qui aurait pu imaginer qu'à
partir de 1re mention on avait un espace
rempli d'armoires avec peu d'instruction
5000 c'était génial à l'époque mais
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment très peu par
rapport à ce que font les petits
microprocesseurs intel autres alors il
ya d'autres inventions
ce que vous voyez à gauche si un boycott
copter c'est tout électrique
aujourd'hui ça existe sur le marché il
peut faire centaines de kilomètres vous
connaissez aussi le solar impulse qui en
2016 a fait le tour du monde qui fait
quarante mille kilomètres également
c'est une équipe suisse qui était au cap
21 pour parler de leur invention
on travaille également énormément sur
les voitures autonomes communicante
j'étais en californie la semaine
dernière une des boîtes a été racheté
par intel qui travaillent uniquement sur
le côté logiciel sur la conduite
autonome elle a été rachetée à 15,3
milliards de dollars parce qu'il ya un
marché énorme
et puis un jour en 2040 rolls royce a
annoncé qu'elle va travailler que sur le
tout électrique avant de donner tout ce
qui est thermique et diesel et autres
donc un marché énorme ceux des voitures
communicantes alors cette voiture aussi
qu'ils vont utiliser les techniques
intelligente c'est à dire que si elle
arrive qu'elles voient un ballon devant
la voiture
elle va commencer à réfléchir en disant
s'il ya un ballon il ya peut-être un
enfant derrière donc je vais essayer de
ralentir même si c'est pas un être
humain mais peut-être l'être humain va
arriver dans défaut que je ralentisse
donc ça c'est tout et techniques de
machine learning ou bien activision
intelligence qui sont utilisés après on
va trouver aussi et tout ce qui est
image 3d
et réalité augmentée et qu'est-ce qui
peut être utilisé dans les industries ce
qui peut être utilisée également dans la
vie et on peut même trop mettre des
puces dans la peau de l'être humain qui
va en fait communiquer des informations
qui vont nous donner l'état de santé de
quelqu'un ça évite en fait d'aller voir
le médecin toutes les 10 minutes et
d'avoir si quelqu'un un état critique le
médecin va recevoir les informations et
pouvoir en fait elle eut envahi les
signaux nécessaires et tout ce qui est
gassion c'est un marché aujourd'hui qui
énorme qu'on est capable d'aller se
balader quelque part dans une ville et
puis on a avec notre iphone un guide
touristique qui va vous dire vous allez
à droite vous allez à gauche etc
alors il y a plus de la moitié de la
population au monde qui sont connectés à
internet
il y a cinq milliards qui ont un
téléphone mobile et même certains en ont
plusieurs
d'accord donc le monde est déjà connecté
on a inventé énormément de choses alors
pourquoi at on besoin de revenir aux
sources
pourquoi l'héritage pourquoi le passé
est toujours utile alors le passé est
toujours utile parce que on pense qu'il
y a une mine d'informations une mine de
renseignements qui peuvent nous aider à
comprendre un petit peu l'avenir
ça veut pas dire que le passé en
extrapolant on peut prédire l'avenir
mais il comprend un certain nombre
d'apprentissages d'information qui une
fois rentrés dans les modèles physiques
mathématiques parfois philosophique
ils vont nous permettre de donner des
informations sur notre avenir
donc aujourd'hui quand on regarde
l'ensemble des données qui sont
collectés sur des machines uniquement 2
% de ces données sont analysées et en
fait quand elles sont analysées c'est à
titre juste informationnel saluons fait
pas trop d'intelligences là dessus donc
tout le reste c'est une mine
d'informations et de renseignements qui
peuvent nous permettre de mieux gérer et
l'efficacité des machines
mieux gérer autre chose alors que ce
soit des données structurées
donc ces camps et bibliothèques
organisée avec des noms des titres etc
des catégories o des données qui sont
non structurées qui viennent un peu de
partout des réseaux sociaux ou de
défende informations de météo etc tous
types de données on n'est pas en train
d'analyser suffisamment c'est d'ailleurs
justement 2% des données qui sont
analysés alors pourquoi on a besoin
d'analyser plus les choses et de revenir
vers le passé pour le comprendre pour
essayer de prévenir et de prédire
l'avenir
alors on va toujours plus d'efficacité
dans les usines on veut toujours plus
d'efficacité dans les infrastructures
dont tout ce qu'on utilise toute
l'infrastructure de transport
aéronautique les aéroports les réseaux
de transport électrique etc
on veut également au niveau de la santé
amélioré notre état de santé
donc il ya beaucoup de choses à
comprendre beaucoup de maladies encore
est-ce qu'on peut prévenir le cancer
avant qu'il arrive
est-ce qu'on peut essayer de comprendre
les rapports un peu au niveau génétique
pour essayer d éviter que quelqu'un
puisse avoir un nom briand qui malade
par exemple on veut que nos villes
soient plus propre avec un minimum des
missions et qu'on puisse se balader de
façon optimisée investir et avoir des
villes qui sont sociales et des villes
qui sont humaines bref on voudrait avoir
un meilleur bien-être
alors c'est pour cela qu'il faut faire
beaucoup plus que voit un frigidaire
connectés que voir un train qui va plus
vite ou que de voir à des ordinateurs
sur des petits processeurs qui font 25
milliards d'instructions par seconde
alors l'économie circulaire c'est un des
bien-être et un des bénéfices également
élu numérique peut jouer un rôle
important en suède
100% des déchets fatou ce qu'on mange
tout ce que j'ai ici 100% recyclé quand
on recycle l'ensemble des déchets
c'est une économie qui est beaucoup plus
boosté c'est une économique et plus
efficace
et même vous êtes capable de faire des
cocktails en faisant un peu de sport le
matin sur ce qui arrive parfois une fois
par an à certains après il faudrait être
capable de prédire et d'améliorer
l'avenir alors comment fait-on alors on
a inventé ce qui s'appelle le jumeau
digital ou numérique certainement pas le
terme digital on va utiliser était
peut-être numérique alors scellé c'est
l'eau s'est pas uniquement un reflet
quand vous voyez c'est sur l'image
c'est pour le comprendre la boîte noire
de l'avion
aujourd'hui comme en a réussi à réduire
le nombre de catastrophes sur les avions
alors premièrement il ya l'association
iata où il ya tous les compagnies
aériennes qui participent
deuxièmement on essaie de tracer toute
l'histoire qu'a vécu ce pauvre avion
depuis qu'on l'a conçu dans les bureaux
d'étude jusqu'à sa fabrication en usine
et ensuite jusqu'à sa mise en
exploitation
alors on sait quel pilote l'a conduit
qu'elle co pilote dans quelles
conditions atmosphériques dans quel pays
qu'il a fait la maintenance tout est
tracé de façon à ce que si jamais ya un
problème on puisse remonter essayer de
comprendre et prévenir et améliorer les
choses au niveau d'avion quand on fait
la même chose également avec tout type
d'équipement que ce soit les centrales
de production que ce soit les éoliennes
que ce soit les autoroutes que ce soit
les aéroports on essaie de trouver les
jumeaux numériques qui permettent en
fait en plaçant des s'en sort ce au
niveau de chaque équipement collecter
l'information température pression
fatigue pour essayer des plus fiables et
éviter que quelques choses s'arrêtent en
cours de route
réduire le nombre de d'accidents et
essayer de faire des économies et
d'avoir un meilleur fonctionnement de
nos installations également au niveau
numérique
on est capable pour les éoliennes
de pouvoir collecter les informations et
on aura en 2020 c'est un objectif qui a
été fixé par la commission européenne
par exemple le repreneur à 20% de nos
énergies qui viendrait de sources
renouvelables
on aura en 2040 peut-être 40 % on aura
un moment en 2050 peut-être 80 % qui
viendront de sources qu'ils soient pas
de sources polluantes
donc là on a besoin aussi de collecter
des informations parce que ce sont des
étudiants distribuent un peu partout sur
le territoire il va y avoir des millions
et des millions et on a besoin au fait
de gérer leur fiabilité et de gérer à
quel moment elle génère de l'énergie
quand on n'en a pas besoin pour la
stocker nos goûts veille avoir de plus
en plus de numérique qui va en fait
calculés et stocker l'information la
nuit pendant qu'on dort pour certains et
puis l'on devrait l'utiliser quand on en
a besoin pour certains ou la plupart
également donc aujourd'hui un potentiel
au niveau des données
il faut le libérer c'est pour ça qu'il
ya de plus en plus de réglementaire il
ya de plus en plus de directives émises
à la commission européenne que ceux qui
détient les informations sur les clients
des clients télécoms des clients
d'énergie et criant transport puissent
les partager avec ceux qui peuvent les
utiliser et innover dessus c'est la clé
d'autres choses mais attention on peut
pas manipuler les données on l'a écouté
aussi données précédentes interventions
et ya le côté privé et côté sécurité et
on sait comment aussi travaillé sur le
côté privé et sécurité de façon à ne pas
avoir de problème avec la manipulation
des données faudrait aussi libéré cette
créativité
aujourd'hui contrairement à l'époque où
j'ai fait mes études et c'est tout le
monde allait faire juste de
l'informatique et voilà la physique
s'attend à rien la technique ça donne à
rien etc
on en a qui peut en retour aux sources
les modèles ont besoin de gens qui
connaissent les maths les modèles ils
ont besoin de champions connaissent la
physique
l'ordinateur ne fait pas tout donc il va
falloir programmée des choses donné lieu
à de la créativité trouver un lien et y
en a qui ont travaillé ça s'appelle des
tamani sur le rapport entre
l'utilisation des ascenseurs et les
femmes enceintes par exemple
immeuble pour me dire à la fin que tient
quand il ya plus de femmes enceintes
dans l'immeuble en dise plus l'ascenseur
donc il faudrait prévoir le nombre
d'heures en fait pour la censure dont il
ya des tas de choses qu'on peut faire
avec les prévisions de façon à relier
les données entre elles mais pour cela
il faudrait développer énormément le
modèle c'est ce qu'on appelle les
dépasse à un test qui ont un background
scientifique physique mathématique
parfois biologique également parce que
dans le sens t on a besoin de ça dont la
santé est aussi un brin informatique qui
permet en fait de développer des modèles
alors on a fait des calculs pour dire si
on gagnait 1 % d'efficacité au niveau de
la consommation par exemple de pétrole
au d'efficacité au niveau de la
productivité dans ce secteur que vous
voyez aéronautique pôle énergie si on
faisait un pour cent d'efficacité on
pouvait gagner 276 milliards de dollars
sur 15 ans et c'est pas rien il ya
d'autres chiffres qui ont été émis par
le world economic forum en 2016 l'
avantage de l'utilisation numérique pour
l'industrie c'est avec 3 trillions de
dollars et pour la société serait de 2
trillions de dollars donc des bénéfices
qui sont énormes pour la société alors
la conclusion que je voudrais vous
donner ce que notre héritage et une mine
de connaissances
ça on l'a vu on a énormément
d'informations il suffit juste de
fouiller dans notre grenier dans notre
placard pour trouver beaucoup de choses
sur le passé peut-être qu'ils peuvent et
il être utile si la mode revient on est
capable également de travailler sur les
technologies numériques pour
effectivement essayé de transmettre un
avenir qui meilleur pour nos enfants
vos enfants si vous en avez même si vous
êtes jeunes dans la salle alors après il
ya la grande question en à des juristes
dans la salle en partie alors le droit
ou l'avancé numérique alors certainement
ils vont jamais être là au bon moment
c'est à dire on va trouver que le droit
parfois est un peu trop sophistiquée par
rapport à la technologie ce qui en
france on va trouver parfois à l'avancé
technologique qui va un peu trop vite à
la google un peu mais là c'est beaucoup
trop vite avant que le droit s'installe
mais in fine en juin un jour ou l'autre
à trouver un point de convergence pour
essayer de se rattraper donc c'est un
combat qui sera éternelle mais il faut
pas que ce soit une barrière à l'avancé
technologique après la créativité
alors moi je dis toujours les gens trop
disciplinés ne font pas des ravages
c'est beau les génisses et des fous que
ce soit dans la peinture que ce soit
dans la créativité technologique que ce
soit dans l'art tout type d'art
également cdc les gens qui doit voir un
brin de folie ce que j'appelle en fait
créativité ce en conformité et avec sa
dynamique avec une créativité qui énorme
qu'on a aucune limite pour la crise et
pour la créativité pour tout ce qu'on
est capable de faire
alors là dessus j'espère que c'était
clair plutôt pas de chinois et merci de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]